The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, so this is
the second part of the class,
and this the last
for the semester.
So I think we've traveled a lot.
We see many difficult
issues I think.
And I want to give
you credit, I think,
for-- during the semester for
being so open, and honest,
and being able to engage
into difficult issues.
And each time that you
guys were presenting you
might remember me
liking you to you
to get deeper into
personal issues
and not just the abstract.
And the reason is because
I think you make a better
case where everyone is
of use you can bring
your own narrative into it.
And I think it's-- overall I
think it has worked and myself
learned so much from the
semester from listening to you,
some of your own personal
discoveries about yourself,
about issues of race,
language, gender, sexuality.
And I give you
lots of gratitude.
It's risky, and because
when you came here,
you didn't know each
other, most of you right?
And yet to be able open yourself
to the difficult questions
and to give answers
that were so thoughtful.
And so-- many of them I
didn't expect some of you
to literally come out
in this class, in a way.
Right?
So I thought that very
well in this class.
So I give you my
respect for that.
So I'm going to
end passing to you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: You get
a little while more,
maybe you've got
things that you feel
you take with you
to the next steps
so that you feel that
all this will come
after you this class might
benefit from anything that you
want share, in terms
of your learning
experience in this
class, and how you think
can bridge those gaps
that we've seen because
of our societies, our families?
So I wasn't here last
Thursday but I watched
the video of the whole
class. [inaudible] too,
actually really impressed
by how you guys brought up
your personal issues.
And so but these are
going to have worked on.
I assume you have to make some.
For this class-- for this
class 40 minutes or so
you have to be
something to bring out.
We'll go to Nicky.
You're going to take a pass?
OK we'll go to Edna.
AUDIENCE: She's
quicker with words.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm not sure
if I fully understand what
I'm supposed to say, but I'm--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Anything.
AUDIENCE: --going to
say what I was thinking.
So for me personally throughout
this class I think I realized--
I explored myself and
my identity way more,
and I think I was forced to ask
questions about myself that I
hadn't.
And for me the main
thing I realized
is like how uncomfortable I
am with being multiracial.
I enjoy being
multiracial but I didn't
realize that there's parts
of me that don't necessarily
fit together, and how I don't
really see myself as one
certain race, or whatever.
And I think the things that with
that were our personal essays,
and definitely free
writing assignments
that one of the guest
professors had us do,
that got pretty deep.
And I was kind of
like, oh crap I
have to write at 9:30 in
the morning, when she first
said that.
But then I really enjoyed it.
And I think like maybe bringing
out more multi-racial topics
next year would be
beneficial to people
to know that that was a
problem with themselves.
And I think also a
really interesting topic
that we went over was--
I think-- What did we call it?
Faking?
Passing, passing-- and
how it's a privilege.
And talking about like all the
controversial issues on that
and don't think I really
also thought about that
before this class.
So that was something
I benefited from.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So you say
faking instead of passing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And it reminded of a comment
Cynthia made back then, right?
That often, when
we think of passing
we think of it as something
which is negative--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: But contained
in that point, which
I remember very well, I
thought very important
that passing should not be
viewed from that perspective.
I say to that point
that we can think
of passing as a normal
survival strategy in a way.
So maybe--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's a nice
segue to think of [inaudible]..
AUDIENCE: I actually
have another one I think.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Say it again?
AUDIENCE: Nothing, can
I have another one?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Sure of
course. [inaudible] [laughter]
AUDIENCE: So I guess
it's sort of hard,
I think it sort of takes
a lot of reflecting--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sort of think about
all that that we've discussed.
Sort of a quick note, one of
things that this class has
sort of solidified for me is
the importance of conversations.
And so I think most of learning
that I've done in this class
and other sort of seminar
based classes sort of pales
in comparison-- or what I've
learned in my technical courses
pales in comparison
to the things
that I learn in
classes like this
because at the end of the day,
I think most of the learning
comes from those around you.
Class needs this.
So, experiences that
they have more so
than what you learn in
these technical classes.
There's a saying that says
five years after you graduate
you won't remember 90%
or whatever of what
you learned in college.
But I think what
you do remember is
these sort conversations
that boil down
to personal experiences.
And so I think, again,
there is a challenge
in this world of
sort of approaching
people who aren't really willing
to have these conversations.
But sort of changing
yourself is the first step.
And I think if everyone
sort of makes this, or has
this realization, takes a step
toward making this change,
It's very idealistic,
but I think
the world be a better place.
And so I think that's
probably one thing that I've
gotten from this class.
AUDIENCE: Go man.
AUDIENCE: Bouncing
off of what Burk said,
I think one way in which I would
like to see his class grow is
the integration of having some
sort of conversation like open
discussion instead of debate
with someone who does not come
from a similar theological--
not theological--
AUDIENCE: Ideological.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Ideological background
as opposed to people
in this class, to try to see
and sort of gain practice
in having a session
with someone who
is a lot different from you,
and developing a common trust,
and come to see each
other's viewpoints
in a way that would be
more informative than what
one could do among a set
like-minded individuals.
AUDIENCE: Let's see.
So one thing that I
enjoyed about this class
I can distinctly
remember one class
that literally blew my mind
I think I turned to Sonny
and was like, oh my gosh.
And that was when
we interrogated
what MIT was as an
institution and where
we sit in this
hierarchy of social--
in the social
hierarchy in the US.
And I think when
coming to MIT I was
willing to give the
institution a free pass a lot
because I felt
that I was getting
a lot from the experience.
But I think now that I'm
senior and all the seniors here
graduate-- last day
of class with you
guys-- now that I'm at this
point where I can think back
on what MIT has
done for me and what
and how it functions
I think I'm better
poised to think more critically
about the institutions I choose
to join future for postgraduate
education and after.
AUDIENCE: So I took this
class as a challenge
to myself because
at the beginning,
I knew about the
prejudices and stereotypes
that I had been taught, and
I wanted to get rid of them.
And I think this has
helped a lot with that
just by hearing everyone else's
perspectives from the readings,
from looking at the world,
by taking a step back
and looking at
things as they are
and not how we were specifically
taught that they are.
And I really appreciate that.
I want to- from here on
I want to move forward
and try to figure
out how to be an ally
from an asian-american
perspective
because a lot of the times
asian-american families
try to be the status quo.
Like my parents have
always taught to try to be,
not explicitly, but implicitly
try to be as white as you can.
And I think that that was
a really difficult lesson
to go through, and then come
to a place like MIT which
is so diverse and which has
so many different backgrounds.
And so come in thinking
there's a hierarchy where
there isn't and
now going forward,
trying to break that down.
AUDIENCE: Related to
what you said actually
is this concept of being
multi-racial, and interrogating
that for yourself.
But also within a context
of being in a society
of multiple races, and
understanding the spaces that
exist for meaningful
conversations
across cultural, and
ethnic, and other sometimes
just socially
constructed boundaries
that don't necessarily
need to be boundaries.
And I remember in one
conversation Cynthia actually
really challenged this idea of
forming alliances especially
between historically,
systematically
oppressed groups.
And in a class
like Black Matters
I think that we actually think
about people who don't identify
as black, and who may not
be read as black in society,
and we've engaged
critically with the issues
that they face as well.
When we talked about immigration
from Mexico, and in other times
where I insist upon
interjecting indigenous
North American issues
into the conversation.
But there seems to be
space for all of that,
and so what I want to take away
from all of these discussions
is how can we create meaningful
alliances, and be allies,
and how can we
collaborate between groups
who are distinct and different,
and face similar challenges
in this society, but also have
really specific perspectives
and experiences,
and future goals.
So the idea of
collaborations, especially
among historically
oppressed groups
is one that I want
to continue thinking
about outside of this class.
AUDIENCE: A lot of what
I was thinking about
during this class
for me personally
was comparing and contrasting
because I come from a very--
I'm from Zimbabwe.
So there's not a
lot of diversity,
and this is an entirely
new experience to me,
so a lot of what
I were doing was
comparing my past, my
history, my experiences
with you guys experiences
and everything around me,
and thinking about for
instance, in the readings
how they analyzed
different situations,
the situation in America,
the situation in Haiti.
And thinking about where
these things are connected
how they are different.
What could have been
done what should be done?
And I think I rarely thought
about issues like this
before this class,
and now I'm starting
to think about it more,
especially in education.
I'm really interested in
education, and how we can help
teach people in the future how
to use their skills that they
learn, how to think about, how
to approach certain problems
in a way that challenges them,
and also challenges the status
quo, and challenges the
hierarchies that are set up.
So personally, I think
that this class definitely
helped me think
a lot more, and I
hope that in future it will
help a lot more people think
about their actions, think
about what they're saying,
think about what
they're doing, and think
about how they can
help and how they
can engage their communities.
For instance, I
remember when we're
talking about how we came
to MIT we might graduate,
and then what are we
going to do would we
go back to the communities
where we come from?
How we are going--
how do you plan
to affect those communities?
Do you go back as experts, or
do we go back as one of them,
do we to fit in?
Questions like
that are definitely
things that we should
think about, and I think
are very important.
AUDIENCE: Yeah I think
the biggest thing
for me was learning about
what we were learning,
but then thinking back to how I
grew up in a really white area,
and I was always taught there
is one correct way to speak,
there is like one correct
way to teach kids.
And thinking back now
with all this information
how damaging that really
is, and how it it's
not really about the language,
and it's not really about
how we speak it's more
about marginalizing groups
that might speak that way.
And it's just thinking about
how my entire school system was
based on what they thought was
correct, and was telling us
what we should think
is correct, and I
think coming out
of this hopefully
we can try to change some of
that in the school systems
because it can really
affect how kids
view the world as they grow up.
AUDIENCE: I think one thing
I gained from this class
is, I guess, verification of
the idea that listening is very
important, and there's
kind of various ways
you can think about it.
Just in the context
of this class,
whether it's listening to other
people share their experiences,
and really taking
in and understanding
how they fit in within
whatever social hierarchy,
or whatever kind of
issue we're discussing.
And seeing how it's kind of
played a role in their lives,
and kind of seeing how you
could apply it to either better
someone else's life,
improve your own interaction
with the world in some way.
Or whether it's listening
in terms of language.
We talked a lot about
language and how
certain modes of speaking
are somewhat marginalized.
So ensuring that as you
go forward you really
listen to people regardless of
how they present their ideas,
or present their
thoughts, or whether it's
listening as far as
engaging people who
have opposing opinions as you.
Really understanding
that in order
to strengthen your
own positions,
and really understand why it is
that you think the way it is.
You have to be able to
listen to people who think
in a different way than you.
So yeah, I've just seen
a lot of different things
in this class that speaks to
the importance of listening.
AUDIENCE: I think
what this class
has made me call into question
a lot is my lack of analysis
of my racial background
because I'm Japanese-American.
It's not really
something that I'm
forced to address all the time
because no one's really calling
that much attention to
it because neither one
of those groups is really that
attacked in modern society
for being a racial group.
And something I didn't
really even think,
my mom is an immigrant.
I didn't really
address that ever
because no one was calling in to
question her immigration here.
And that also leads
to a lot relating
to how the opinions of
other people, and especially
my very conservative
extended family,
and how their opinions
about certain things
such as immigration are
relying on people being
of certain races, and being
from certain places because it
isn't something that
they've ever seen negatively
about my family.
But it is something that's
a cornerstone of why
my family exists.
So I think things like
that, having people address
their own identities,
and their own backgrounds
and how that's
affected how they see
everything else in their
interactions with other people
I think is a really great
part of this course.
AUDIENCE: I'm having trouble
just to lay everything down,
but I guess one big
takeaway from this class
was accepting that
there is no one right
way to exist as a human across
individuality, race, and class,
and things like that.
And that was a
realization that I
think I came to in this class.
And it all goes back
to the importance
of interrogating
your beliefs, and why
you think the ways that you do.
And it's really
eye-opening and I think
that it's really important.
You have to open
yourself up to that
and it takes a certain
level of vulnerability.
I wasn't expecting to come
out in this class at all,
but I did because this was
a place where I felt safe,
and it was really
surprising that I felt
so safe in this environment.
And I think that's something
we need to recreate elsewhere.
A lot of people I would like
to take for this in the future
is therapy who are
seniors taking this class,
what do you do now?
What class do you take
next, or what actions
can you take because of what
you've learned in this class?
I think something
that maybe they
could have it in this is
thinking about concrete ways
to actually do stuff.
Because we had Professor Chomsky
in here on Tuesday and he said,
almost anything, is the
answer to what do we do.
So maybe having some sort of an
initiative coming out of this
class is to make tape just
at MIT for just impulsive
[inaudible]..
AUDIENCE: So kind
of piggybacking off
of what Chris said,
I think the most
those meaningful
conversations and talks
that we've had for me, where
when we talked to professors,
people all over
Cambridge who were using
their own backgrounds,
their own field of study,
and they're making
tangible changes.
It's Christmas day.
So for example, when we
watch the virtual reality
kind of simulation in terms
of the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict.
And I feel like those
conversations and the fact
that I have had the
privilege of taking
this class in my semester
has really kind of driven me
to really to take
action outside of MIT,
and hopefully in the
future back at MIT.
And to really take that
with me in my specific field
of medicine, and how these
various identities can really
affect people's health care,
and that's life or death.
And so I feel like that is
really been eye-opening for me
and that's driven me to action.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
for me, from this class
has made me more aware of how
many things they go through.
Compared to what I didn't know
about the Haitian Revolution
as it occurred.
And I didn't really know how
to question during the time.
But it's all things
that we are taught just
because a lot the
history that we
learn is taught from a very
westernized perspective.
So I feel like
it's very important
that this class teaches that
there's always many ways
to view certain things, and
there's many things that aren't
necessarily taught just because
society just doesn't want us
to know about these
things, so that we
could learn from this, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think similar
to what Hermann was saying,
I think this class is
really about the idea
of taking action.
In a lot our readings passivity
was just there all the time.
People I remember it,
the need to settle down,
or afternoon it's just like,
oh that's really strange
but I guess the way things are.
He noticed that things were
wrong but he didn't anything,
so I think just
trying to take action,
and Megan you mentioned
interrogating yourself
is an important way to do it.
And I really liked
first assignment,
which was the linguistic
autobiography,
and I felt that just thinking
of my whole life in terms
of the languages I grew
up with, reading, writing,
and how they were
presented to me
was a really good way just
to look into my own self.
What I think would have
been, would be better,
in future versions of class
would be maybe talking together
in smaller groups.
Would be harder.
I guess I think it's
just easier just
to talk about yourself
that way for some people
are more comfortable, I think.
The only time we got to
that was last Tuesday we
had Professor Olive ub here, and
we worked in groups of three,
and that was really cool.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank
you, thank you.
I think so what's adjusted also,
you mean like a [inaudible]..
So what Chris said
we can try together
because this class I hope
will be often many, many,
many, many times again
here, [inaudible] I hope.
Actually thinking of next
year, I might do it with
[inaudible]..
So from that perspective
maybe you guys
could share with
me what you think
will be done to implement
what you guys think
in terms of taking this
knowledge into action.
Because throughout
the semester I
was struggling with what
kind of project do I assign?
Because I often
felt that it would
be so nice to do a project that
puts you guys in the world,
not just writing an essay.
And I try to see what--
Something could come
up spontaneously
from you that could
bond in to out of space.
So how would you advise me
in next cycle of this course
to make that happen?
To do projects, maybe
throughout the semester only
or optional projects
that would really
turn knowledge into action?
OK so it's getting
that, and then that.
AUDIENCE: So,
maybe some things--
I still think you should
have the essays because
at least for me they were pretty
beneficial in exploring myself,
but maybe instead of
having the essay revision,
although I think revising
essays is important,
I think that can be done
throughout your essay process
instead.
And maybe like putting
in a project where
you have to create a policy,
or like a lesson plan,
or something like that,
and then present that.
And maybe even have a
plan of action of who you
would go to talk to about this?
I think if you just
come up with a plan it
can be pretty philosophical,
or just an idea
and will never be
done with it, what
would be your next step
now you have an idea,
how do you implement it?
And then also, something
I forgot mention before,
but I thought I was really
useful about this class
was when we went
to go to the movies
all together on a Saturday.
At first I was like, oh crap,
now I have to like allot time,
but I actually
really enjoyed that
and was hoping the
conversation would keep going.
So maybe having more
things outside the class,
because I think it's really
hard to explore all the things
that we want to do in
an hour and a half.
So maybe having somewhere--
I don't know what
types of places
you can go to-- but maybe
going to an inner city
school in Boston together, and
seeing how it's taught there,
and what you would change?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, that's
good to hear actually
because one thing I'm toying
with the Fox, Mr. Harald,
is to see whether we could
change the format, instead
having a hour and a half to add
once a week from three hours.
In the past I tried that
because of the schedule for MIT
it's hard for students to
enroll with a three hour class.
when they graduate.
So we stepped away
from that, but now
I don't whether
we should do that.
In admitting with three hours
we could go someplace else.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I that
might be beneficial.
I know negotiation at Sloan
does it at Thursday at 5:00
or something like that.
So it's hard to schedule a
three hour class during the day,
but if you do it
as a night session.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK, OK.
Thank you for saying that Alisa?
I will report back to
Colton and see what--
So it goes Dana, then
Sarah then Jackie.
AUDIENCE: Well its
related directly
she just said about time--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK.
AUDIENCE: It's just
like a short thing,
but having a class at
5:00 would be difficult
because there is
a lot of athletes
who participate because they
practice from 5:00 to 7:00.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
I see, I see, OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah there's
another section at 7:00
I'm pretty sure.
So.
AUDIENCE: Closing class
are from 7:00 to 10:00.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
7:00 to 10:00, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah we were
talking about projects.
And I think that could
definitely work in this course,
and I think one thing that I've
really wanted is to be able
to affect change in this--
within the context of this
course and sort of have a reason
to do so based on everyday's--
I would like to go
into school and say,
let me try my at
teaching kids in this way
and see if it
actually works there.
So if you wanted to
organize that sort of thing
it could be cool to also
work in small groups
and we diversify the--
I mean we have a ton
of courses in here,
but I think there's a
lot of working, going out
into the real
world and I think--
I mean this is just me agreeing.
I think a three hour
course could be good.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
Sarah?
AUDIENCE: So I just
think add stems
from what Colin
said about talking
to someone with a different
ideological perspective
than yourself, so
maybe having students
go in groups of two [inaudible]
out into world and maybe
interview someone, or share
some of the information
about the Haitian
Revolution should have,
it was like one of visionary
revolutions to have.
[interposing voices]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Something
along those lines.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK, OK.
So going back to the last point.
So in terms of going
into the schools
I have some good
news, which is that, I
think I should have [inaudible]
with you about this new program
that has been launched in
the Boston public school,
this new program.
And Vindlam Khan actually
she's I think Chinese,
and she actually, she
launched-- she had launched
the program in
Chinese and English
can be introduced as
going reasonable well,
from what I hear.
And then she's also responsible
launching this Creole
to English learning program.
And she has offered
that if there
are students in this
class and other classes
at MIT if they want to come and
volunteer, and take advantage
of that new program in terms
of doing research that's
socially based, or
empirically based,
or even like [inaudible].
Measuring students
learning games
she would be happy
to work with you.
There's one student
in the other class
posted it's [inaudible]
with the [inaudible] twice,
and was to be going
on a weekly basis
to the meetings who try
understand how they are
creating this new program
where there would be I
think half kids who
speak creole and half who
don't speak creole.
And this would be
truly bilingual,
so you get American or other
of these kids learning creole
and get the Haitian creole kids.
We've got to include both the
English and bigger English,
so I think it's really I
think very radical move
for the government school.
They've had other
programs of that sort
but never one involving
the non-imperial language.
Typically it's Spanish-English,
French-English,
Chinese-English, but
it's the first time
that they are doing
one that includes
a language like Haitian Creole
that's been over the years
as you know [inaudible] history.
So we're excited, we've
hit some push back
including push back back from
Haitian parents, some of them
would prefer to have it in
French, as you can imagine.
They don't speak French,
it's a difficult neo-colonial
[inaudible] into an imperial
language, so to speak.
But I think there has been some
good progress on that front.
Noam Chomsky was
here, Tuesday he
had an interview which I
put on my Facebook page--
I can show it to you--
where it goes me,
him, and I think that's
[inaudible] together
from Mexico, but he
grew up in California.
And this was a very interesting
exchange between the two of us.
Where Chomsky might be
important of promoting these so
called [inaudible]
support for really
of duration of the [inaudible].
So, I think those
are good suggestions,
those are very good suggestions.
And since Harrell is from a
background in computation,
and as we saw doing the project
on involving virtual reality
that might be another part where
we can do action in the course.
AUDIENCE: With the-- just
based off like the Fox Harrell
computation part, I thought it
was really interesting learning
about what he was doing.
I think if there was--
but I don't know if this
is where you're going, but it.
I think there was a
more of a requirement
to do more computation based
things I probably would
straight away from this class.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
AUDIENCE: Because, so I'm not
like the stereotypical major
here, I'm a business
major, I think
I would been slightly
intimidated if there
was a CMS type project in here.
So maybe making that one of
the facets of what you can do,
but not a requirement.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, that's OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah,
good for you, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CYNTHIA: I think also taking
advantage of the learning
styles of the students in the
class could be interesting.
So maybe doing more
creative projects,
or doing projects
that people feel
like allows them to
use their best skills
and actually have
fun I feel like--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So tell
me Cynthia if you could
a project that was creative
what would you have done?
Just to the extent of what you
could think of in the future?
CYNTHIA: Just off
the fly I maybe would
have made a fucking 10 foot
tall papier-mache person
and written stuff all over it
and then put it in lobby 10.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK.
AUDIENCE: Like negative
comments or like--
CYNTHIA: Anything, just like
stuff that's interesting.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
OK, and then they
would have to the part
that includes communication
of some sort.
So how would do
that, so you do that
and have a paper
describing why you did it,
the mission of what you've
done and the objective
it's trying to accomplish?
CYNTHIA: I mean if it
just like a black body
or like a brown
body of some sort
I would even just to
leave markers and stuff
for other people to
put messaging on it
I feel like would be giving--
I think art is a great
way to give people
an entry into having
this conversation.
It would be an artifact.
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
Excellent, excellent I'm
so glad this is being recorded
so that way we have this.
No really, so that
way we have this--
I can watch it with
Fox, Carol and we
then we can play around with
the idea, it's great too.
Actually, anyone has concrete
suggestions like that?
So they told you--
AUDIENCE: So my class one
of those I don't-- maybe
you've taken it, Psychology
of Gender and Race?
No?
OK.
This [inaudible] psychologist
who works in local area,
I think her first name is
Shiby I forget her last name.
But part of the class is
training or doing mock training
on how do you present cultural
awareness presentations.
Where you go with--
you basically
form a group of students
and kind of teach
the other students her role
play and how to college frat,
members of a college
frat or sixth graders
out of a local
Boston public school
about how some things
that they could be doing
may be disparaging
to minority groups,
and it could be interesting
having a conversation with her
to see what things
she incorporates
into those presentations
and if that would be
useful inside of Black Matters.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, that would
be useful, be very useful.
Dana?
No I was-- I'm done.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK. [laughter]
AUDIENCE: With the
wiki that I think
was a new thing this
semester, I think,
it's another way for us to
communicate as students,
it would be great because
just maybe someone
said something to you that
was really interesting
and you only have their email.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Right.
AUDIENCE: It's hard to get in
contact so maybe an opt-in way
to have--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So the wiki
didn't really work, huh?
Why does the wiki not work?
AUDIENCE: It's hard.
AUDIENCE: It's not
a good platform.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: The wiki
is not a good platform,
all because we have you
here. [laughter] The wiki not
a good platform, I heard that
as well in my other class,
the students say, we
don't like the wiki.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[interposing voices]
AUDIENCE: What about
like a Slack Channel
or something like where you
be more-- [interposing voices]
AUDIENCE: Or like a Facebook,
something that we already
all use and wouldn't have
to go out our way to use.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Who
had their hand raised?
Was there a hand
raised over here?
Was it Shope, was
your hand raised?
Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah sure.
So first, you were asking
what kind of projects right?
So from the teaching
perspective,
I think after the
classes last week I'm
learning about open
and fixed mindset.
Something that would
have been interesting
as the project would be to
create a curriculum, just
a lecture or a workshop for
an age group, whatever age,
it could be college,
it could be lower
and try to implement
the like teaching
techniques that we learned to
foster a more open mindset.
That would have been a
school project to explore.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, great.
OK so, Fenny, Dana and Edna.
AUDIENCE: But mine
is off of that.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I think
that would be a good idea.
Also we can still enlist the
help of the professors who
made these lectures because
I think that will give us
a little more-- when we
actually go into these schools
and say we'd like to bring
this plan to you because have
professor backing, we
have this whole slew
of research behind us.
AUDIENCE: Another cool thing
that you could do about
community outreach, is I know
one time a couple weeks ago
in Amphibious Achievement we
had a bunch of people from
Chocolate City come in, and
also it's-- there's a group--
it's like something
something Latinas.
And I don't know--
[interposing voices] Yes!
And so they came in and
Chocolate City came in and--
AUDIENCE: But you have to give
some background about Chocolate
City and Amphibious Achievement,
make it self-contained.
[interposing voices] So
Amphibious Achievement
is we-- it's a program at MIT
and we work with Boston public
high schoolers and it's an
academic mentorship program,
but also we just
work with them to try
to build their
confidence, and we also
help them apply to college,
and things like that.
But, and then Chocolate
City is just like it's
a living group here on campus,
and it's African-American men
and then-- say it again?
AUDIENCE: Mujeres Latinas.
AUDIENCE: That's a-- [laughter]
AUDIENCE: --group
of Latina women,
and so they came in to
talk to the high schoolers
in Amphibious Achievement and we
just had a discussion about how
they feel about what they've
been told they can and cannot
do because of who they are.
And it was really, really
interesting for everybody.
And I think that would
be something cool to do--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Do you
have a Facebook page?
AUDIENCE: We do, it's called
Amphibious Achievement.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Right.
That's great.
Thank you, thank you.
Actually, so which Facebook
would be a better way
to communicate instead the wiki.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah way better.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Way better.
So maybe next year we create a
Facebook page for the course.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, a
page for the course
and then a messaging
group for the students.
OK, OK.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, OK that
was good idea, good idea.
All right.
I should maybe
[inaudible] a page,
a Facebook page for this
group, and that way you guys
can keep in touch.
And if there are ways that--
even what [inaudible] has
explained and then we should do
other projects that might bring
your strength and your
knowledge together
to bring actual
change, that might be
something we could figure out.
But you would have be
responsible for it.
Colin?
AUDIENCE: Bouncing
off of your idea here,
I think it would be really
interesting to actually
have one part of that would be
a [inaudible] support literacy
class, or presentation
or something like that.
Where you going to take a
certain section of literature,
maybe just one book
like Madam Bovary,
and dissect the ways in
which the society in which it
is embedded create
the themes within it.
A major thing inside
of Madam Bovary
is centered on this
one woman who's
married in countryside of
France back in 1900s or 1800s,
and she gets really depressed
because she has nothing to do.
And just explaining that she
has no options for employment,
and is stuck at home because
that's what was expected
of women back in that day.
And dissecting both
that cultural phenomenon
and then examining how that
may play out in today's terms
with different
patterns in society.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, good, goo.
SO a statistic fact, you
may have the last word.
AUDIENCE: Wow, OK.
So something that I
was thinking about
was what you had about
having an art project,
and I realized I'm not artistic
at all, so I was trying
to figure out what I would do
if there was an art assignment.
And I was thinking about
something that's in a show,
where like you put yourself
up, you stand up there
and then you have
a projector screen,
and you write
words on it of what
you don't like about yourself.
And that could be
instead of what
we don't like of
ourselves, things
we've been told about ourselves
based of our race, or gender,
or sexuality, and also having
things you would rather
have been said, because what I
really liked about this class
was the self-exploration, so.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Good, good.
All right guys so
thank you so much.